we're with Nick Ragone actually who had
who is a player about 1600 out there and
you had a chance to ring the bell room
with all these stars little nerd you
feel I was a little scared I didn't want
to ring it prematurely and get the guys
rattled and just see all the players
there I mean I my son and I he's 10
Frankie's out there were just such big
fans of all the players and to be able
to ring the bell was a great thrill and
I was just glad I didn't do it
prematurely and rattle them a little bit
get them off their game you wouldn't get
them off the game everybody just think
you're an idiot they already think that
no not at all now we know ascension is
committed to helping 20 schools in the
st. Louis area why does ascension feel
this is an important initiative for you
to be supporting well you know if you
look at the last year in the st. Louis
area too it's been a challenging one we
all know that and we felt like what's a
way for us to give back beyond just wear
a healthcare provider just beyond health
care and really help the community come
together and we're starting with you
know we'll hopefully with your help and
the next two weeks we'll be announcing
this program are bringing chess to the
middle schools of the Ferguson area but
our goal released encourage other
businesses in the area to do something
similar and we we want to bring chest to
every school in the st. Louis area and I
think you know chess I have a
ten-year-old and an eight-year-old and
they play in their school and it's great
it helps the kids learn discipline and
patience and planning it reinforces math
skills and I just think it's a wonderful
i call it a sport i know some people
call it a game i think it's a sport it's
i think it reinforces some great
qualities that they take throughout life
and I think chess is a wonderful game I
played my kids you could play it for
life and so we're really excited and we
hope it encourages other businesses to
do the same chess in every school that
is an amazing hopefully in the nation
someday that is amazing they are all
working towards ya so tell me the sink
filled Cup what what do you think about
the sink filled cup and also the chess
club and scholastic center st. Louis how
is that impacting everything that's
going on outside along with your
initiatives I mean if you and I had a
chance to talk to Rex briefly and meet
him for the first time but I think chess
is now the epicenter I mean take Louis
is the epicenter of chess not only in
this country I think in the world and
that is such a special unique privilege
that we have
and Rex has done an amazing job creating
an environment where you know the best
and brightest in our game are now coming
here and I think for us at ascension you
know we're headquartered here we have
1200 employees here we have 150,000
across the country but to be in st.
Louis where where the epicenter of chess
and for us to be able to sort of bring
our passion for taking care of
communities through chess it's just a
great opportunity a great partnership
and like I said it's starting here I
hope that you know in the next five
years we're talking about every school
in this country having after school
chess activities I just think it would
give us such a leg up on our ability for
our young people to reinforce learning
to reinforce planning and patience and
math amuse excuse that we know chess is
related to so I'm very excited but I
think Rex has done an amazing amazing
job creating such an environment here
where where chess can flourish it makes
us special great points and of course
we've many of us here including the
commentators in in the studio have done
this exact sort of work for the same
reason so we applaud what you're doing
but I have to ask I mean if you're a
1600 player you've got to take on Rex I
mean we're gonna I think we're having
lunch next week and we read another
bring a chess set well we believe that
we both play the accelerated dragon on
black so it'll it'll one of us to get a
win big or lose big you kiki them
secrets are ready I have no poker face
I'm gonna learn a new maybe you guys
give me a new opening I'm sure you know
tricks to beat wreck so tell me the main
trick to be rice is to talk to his
trainer gencha hottie okay all right
she'll she'll give you some why do I
play the Spanish I play the rouille
lopez from hoping maybe he doesn't know
anything on that too I don't know he
probably just knows the name and that's
it yeah that's where about that well we
thank you so much for being with us and
we applaud the work you're doing keep up
the great thank you thanks so much Nick
Nick ragone with ascension health doing
great work here in st. Louis Community